[Music]
the only law that modest is gravity you
ever look at someone and wonder what is
going on inside their head standing
south never phone after all my pride is
all I got respect is all I want and I
will never throw this race so I'll run
for where I because look at the man that
I've become look up in the sky as long
as the Sun cries I'll be on this rock
why'd you wait for this
the world oh she's looking at us what
did she say whoa oh sorry sir no one's
listening is it garbage night
ah so Riley how was school ghosts are
real
this much I know you
Riley I do not like
I don't know where this disrespectful
attitude came from
[Music]
that's it go to your room can't let one
small meltdown destroy where I was doing
and what I was doing boats always
searched second chance doesn't want a
second chain
can I pretend to do
every person matters the future isn't
just something that happens it's a
brutal force with a great sense of humor
for me this is life taking the planet
until I'm convalescing I never got my
blessings I only count the cost
living it's hard to buy everything they
sell in color
we got my dreams
and not just wait
don't create with only
people would sit down
back up it's not the end of the world
although one man killed
like that sometimes this
simple
one two three let all your feet
let him know right
standing tall never fall after all my
Friday's all I got respect is all I
bought and I will never